it's seven o'clock this is Skinny's
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning Russia says three military
personnel have been killed by Falling
wreckage from Ukrainian drone shot down
over an air base southeast of Moscow
retailers hope to move unsold winter
stock with bigger Boxing Day discounts
as they grapple with budget squeezed
Choppers and another day of Transport
disruption
retailers like those here in central
London could face further setbacks where
trains not running today as strikes
continue
police hunt for a gunman who fired
several shots at a pub near Liverpool
killing a young woman who was out for
Christmas drinks
I'll have the latest life from the scene
here in wallasey Village as another man
remains in a critical condition in
hospital following the incident
at least 50 people are now known to have
been killed in almost unprecedented
winter storms sweeping North America
dual British Nationals are amongst
several people arrested in Iran over
anti-government protests
warnings about what lies ahead this
winter after a sharp rise in the number
of homeless people dying in Scotland
the plight of those struggling and
living rough was a focus of the Kings
the king's Christmas address we look at
how the papers reacted
in sport Mikhail arteta calls for
leaders Arsenal to keep their standards
up as the Premier League returns after
the World Cup
and the Weather colder with sunshine and
showers for most wintry on the Hills
especially over Scotland but many
Eastern paths will be fine
foreign
welcome to Sky News breakfast Russia
says three of its military personnel
have been killed by Falling debris from
a Ukrainian drone which it says it shot
down over an air base the Engels
Airfield in The Saratov region of South
East of Moscow was hit earlier this
month in what Russia said were Ukrainian
drone attacks it's a major Russian
bomber operations base well Skies Easter
Elder gear is in care for us this
morning and how significant are these
deaths Yusuf
I mean it's very significant but it's
also important to note that the
statement given to Russian news agencies
doesn't say that the Drone hit the base
it says that the Drone was approaching
the base at a low altitude and the
falling wreckage of it being shot down
is what killed those three Russian
military personnel now this is a huge
still a huge reputational blow to Russia
Engels is a very important Strategic Air
Base a lot of the recent airstrikes
coming out of Moscow in recent weeks
have been from Engels and so there is a
sense of
embarrassment at the moment that this is
twice in recent weeks that angles has
been hit the last hit was on December
5th and now just on the morning after
Christmas day another happens meanwhile
here in Ukraine yesterday on Christmas
Day Russia rained down missiles on towns
across the country you know reportedly
more than a dozen attacks as people came
together to break away from Russian
Traditions some of them to celebrate
Christmas on the Gregorian calendar
instead of Eastern tradition to
celebrate on January 7th and now this
double strike could fuel a retaliatory
uptick of airstrikes from Russia
thank you very much
now police say a 26 year old woman
killed in a pub shooting on Christmas
Eve was shot in the head and was not
believed to have been deliberately
targeted four men were heard during the
incident at the Lighthouse Pub in
wallersley village on merseyside one
remains in a critical condition or
merseyside police say that the attack
took place at a time when the pub was
crowded with people enjoying a night out
the fact that this has happened on
Christmas Eve makes the tragedy even
more impalatable and shows those
responsible have no regard for members
of the public who just want to be able
to live their lives without fear
at the time the offender fired the gun
there were a large number of people
enjoying a night out at the Lighthouse
Inn
and the actions of the gunman were
totally and utterly Reckless
I'm joined Now by our correspondent at
the scene Fraser Morden Fraser what more
do we know about what happened that
night
well from what we know from The Briefing
that police gave us the most recent
information from police is that a gunman
approached the front of the building in
front of the pub there the lighthouse
behind me and started firing apparently
indiscriminately we heard eyewitness
reports talking of several gunshots of
volley of fire uh five shots in very
quick succession followed by a short
pause another couple of shots another
couple of shots after that so
potentially up to nine or ten rounds
were fired just towards the entrance of
the pub the police say it was totally
Reckless it was callous it was brutal it
was cold-blooded and during that brief
uh brief volley of gunfire sadly the 26
year old woman was hit in the head she
was taken to Arrow Park Hospital about
six miles away from here where sadly
attempts to save her life failed other
people have been injured a 28 year old
man remains in a critical condition in
hospital after receiving gunshot wound
to his body and then three other people
also Receiving Hospital treatment for
gunshot wounds one who was hitting the
legs one in the hand one in the wrist
those injuries are not thought to be
life-threatening so police have launched
the murder investigation of course gun
crime and Firearms incidents were
brought into sharp focus in Liverpool in
August this year when three killings
took place three shootings took place
within the space of of just a couple of
weeks one of them the death of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell in in
her own home Ashley Dale Sam rimmer the
other two victims one man has been
charged in his appeared in cause and
pleaded not guilty to uh to the merger
of Olivia Pratt called Bell but in terms
of the other incidents the arrests have
been made and several arrests have been
made and when people have been released
either under investigation or on police
bails so police are very keen to point
out that gun crime has been brought more
under control here in Liverpool than in
the past there have been fewer shooting
incidents in the last two years than in
many of the previous years and police
say that they are making concerted
efforts to try and make the streets
safer in terms of this investigation
we've seen forensic officers down here
taking away bags of evidence for further
examination door-to-door inquiries have
been underway a lot of CCTV footage has
been handed into police and they say
they've had a very positive response
particularly from people who were inside
the pub enjoying their Christmas Eve
before this incident happened there's
also CCTV from the car park of the pub
and police believe that the gunman once
he'd carried out his attack made his
getaway in a dark colored Mercedes
A-Class car we believe there is footage
of that on CCTV from the uh from the pub
car park which has been handed over to
police and that's one of their major
lines of inquiry but of course they're
wanting anyone with any information
about this tragic incident to come
forward and give it to the police as
soon as possible
Fraser thank you
Shoppers hoping for Boxing Day Bargains
are facing traffic jams and delays is
another round of rail strikes keep
trains at a standstill after Christmas
it's another headache for retailers
hoping to shift extra stock left on the
shelves during a disappointing December
some started their sales early and say
they're offering bigger rejections well
cyber Chowdhury is in central London and
she can tell us more and Saba are people
queuing there
good morning well it's still a little
bit early for that although I should say
I am honest I should be honest that I
thought there would have been more
people at this point in the morning but
clearly not now uh traffic jams for
later in the day should be expected and
that's because thousands of people have
been forced to make alternative travel
plans and that is because of the ongoing
rail strikes that we have been seeing at
these past few weeks now typically on
boxing day there are hundreds of trains
uh operating and uh this is of course
the day after the Christmas shutdown
that we usually see at this time of year
but the rmt union its members are on
strike and that's until tomorrow 6 a.m
uh in the morning now this is of course
a pay dispute with the government the
union I'm asking for more money
government saying we simply cannot
afford it and because of that the AAA
predicting more than 15 million cars
will be on the road later today and
that's across the United Kingdom now
these strikes have also meant that sales
this year with some brands have come
early so we're here on carnaby street
they're around 100 or so shops and some
of those are expected to have already
started their sales now an example of
some shops that have started their sales
a week or so early John Lewis and
debnam's they're going up to 80 percent
off and that's simply because of
excessive stock the rail strikes have
had a significant impact on consumers
going out to the shops and for that
reason the businesses understandably are
very keen to shift as much as they can
today it's quite bad some experts are
saying with one particular person
calling it a sign of distress in this
particular Market it now these strikes
compounded with the cost of living
crisis mean that it is expected that
less people will be spending money
compared to previous years on boxing day
but surely this will not come as a
surprise to many people as the cost of
living crisis has affected just so many
of us
Sarah thank you
well to that huge winter storm hit in
Canada and the United States now or at
least 50 people on Ireland to have died
hundreds of thousands of homes with
businesses were without power on
Christmas day with the so-called bomb
Cyclone stretching from the great lakes
near Canada to the Rio Grande along the
border with Mexico our U.S correspondent
James Matthews has this report
these Christmas storms continue to bite
much of North America has shivered in
scenes like these for several days
blizzards unrelenting have rolled
through Christmas Day
this was buffalo in Upstate New York of
many places badly affected it was among
the worst all of us think in historic
and epic terms but this one is for the
ages and we're still in the middle of it
we still have people who need to be
rescued we have people with their power
off in our communities and uh buildings
where pipes are bursting and flooding is
occurring as is happening in my own home
right now so this is what's happening in
real time it is a devastating experience
I cannot overstate how dangerous the
conditions still are
this so-called bomb Cyclone has left
destruction in its wake and death too
a number of people have been killed on
the roads in white out conditions
these are pictures of Emergency Services
attending a fatal bus crash in British
Columbia Canada the vehicle rolled over
in icy conditions
travel chaos that saw thousands of
flights canceled in the run-up to
Christmas so our last Dash on the day
itself the last of the bomb Cyclone is
forecast to blow through in the coming
hours here it leaves behind a Christmas
they'll remember as one they want to
forget
James Matthews Sky News in Washington
also this morning several people
including durable British Nationals have
been arrested by Iran's revolutionary
guard after anti-government protests
that have been going on for months State
media reports they're the main leaders
of the demonstrations and some of those
rounded up had been trying to leave the
country Sky News understands the foreign
office is investigating the reports
an avalanche in the Austrian Alps has
turned out to be less serious than
initially feared a large rescue
operation was launched in the area
between the results of Lech and zurs but
all 10 of those being searched for have
now been found
French prosecutors say a 69 year old man
accused of killing three Kurdish people
told investigators of his hatred of
foreigners the suspect was arrested on
Friday after two men and a woman were
shot dead at a cultural at a Kurdish
cultural center and nearby cafe in Paris
he's said to appear before a magistrate
today
dozens of people have been taken to
hospital in eastern Serbia after a
freight train carrying ammonia derailed
a state of emergency has been declared
in the town of pirot locals are being
told to stay indoors with Windows sealed
ammonia gas leaks and toxic are toxic
and can be flammable
the King has used his first Christmas
Day broadcast to express sympathy for
those trying to struggle with the cost
of living crisis it was an historic
first address both for King Charles
personally and the UK as it marks the
first time a male Monarch has made a
televised address on the 25th of
December at this time of great anxiety
and hardship
be it for those around the world facing
conflict famine or natural disaster
or for those at home finding ways to pay
their bills to keep their families fed
and warm I particularly want to pay
tribute to all those wonderfully kind
people who so generously give food or
donations or that most precious
commodity of all that time to support
those around them in greatest need
and reaction to the king's address
dominates this morning's papers the
mirror focuses on Charles's praise for
NHS workers and sympathy for people
struggling with bills
the times also reports on the king using
the address to commend tireless health
workers
king of caring says he expressed with a
picture of the royal family on Christmas
morning
a similar take in the Daily Mail which
also says the king spoke of a time of
great hardship
while the sun has the headline the king
of hearts and also focuses on his
tribute to his late mother the queen
the telegraph says the king spoke of a
time of hardship but also hope
away from the royals the I says the
government is poised to abolish most NHS
targets next year so the Health Service
is run more like a localized school
system
the guardian says that the number of
stay-at-home fathers has leapt by a
third since the pandemic
well as we mentioned cost of living was
one of the big issues for the king in
his Christmas address with a new year
around the corner are there any signs
that things could improve and how can we
get our personal finances prepared for
2023 while the independent financial
advisor Vanessa Barnes is here to give
us some insight uh Vanessa great to
speak to you it's been a really tough
year for so many people hasn't it what
are your top tips for the year ahead
I think um well if 2020 told us anything
it was we can't predict what what's
going to happen in the next 12 months
but the we are where we are and
everybody's struggling and we would
recommend that everybody look at the
personal finances we've probably all
splashed out a little bit too much over
Christmas now's the time to sit down
most of the members of the personal
finance society would recommend doing a
written budget so look at the things
that you absolutely have to spend your
money on and maybe try and save a little
cut a little bit back on the areas that
you don't have to spend your money well
obviously with things like electricity
bills being really really high there are
things that people will will really sort
of struggle to say well like you know I
can't really cut back on that so it's
one thing cutting out luxuries but when
it comes to to Heating and eating these
are things people just can't really cut
back on are they no they can't I mean
one of the things that you can do is
talk to the providers if you're really
struggling and if you're having problems
in lots of different areas and fill the
you're fighting too many fires many
members actually work on a pro bono
basis with the citizen advice Bureau and
maybe they can approach there for a
referral and talk to people about how
they can manage different facets of
their personal finances
and in terms of inflation obviously it's
been really high this year what are your
hopes for the next year do you think it
will stabilized do you think it will
come down well what seems to be
happening at the moment is that the rate
of increase is slowing so we would hope
that we're reaching it certainly seems
to have peaked a bit more ahead of us in
America so hopefully we will see that
happen over here I think while things
are going on as they are in the Ukraine
there's a problem in you know Europe
wide with inflation and until that
solution is is is achieved I think it's
going to be very difficult to see the
end of these very very pressing times
and of course just a couple of weeks ago
we saw interest rates going up again and
that's a real concern for those with
mortgages and what are your top tips for
getting through that this next year
there'll be people who are on fixed rate
mortgages or on kind of mortgages that
aren't necessarily affected but there'll
be others are on trackers or those
who've got mortgages to renew over the
next year
early intervention would be the top tip
so if you think that you're going to be
coming off a fixed rate and you've got a
couple of months to go get in early with
your existing provider and compare that
there's lots of comparison sites on the
web that you can have a look at to look
at what would be the best deals for you
talk to a specialist about maybe looking
at if you're on a bite I know that lots
of people are struggling where they've
perhaps put their life savings into a
buy to let so again there are specialist
lenders in that area if you think you're
struggling the best thing you can do is
talk to the mortgage provider as soon as
you can don't wait until the debt
overwhelms you
okay A bit gloomy but but good advice
nevertheless uh Vanessa Barnes thanks
very much for joining us on boxing day
pleasure
good morning you're watching Skinny's
breakfast our top stories this morning
Russia says three if it's military
personnel have been killed by Falling
wreckage from a Ukrainian drone shut
down over an Airbase Southeastern Moscow
retails are fearing a tough end of the
year with a cost of living crisis and
Strikes likely to hit the Boxing Day
sales
at least 50 people have now died in a
huge winter storm that's brought days of
Arctic conditions across Canada and the
United States and even into northern
Mexico
250 homeless people in Scotland died
last year that's much higher than before
the pandemic now we're soaring bills
threatened to push more people into
hardship volunteers say the number of
homeless people has surged and they're
concerned about the winter months ahead
our Scotland correspondent chronograph
reports give
it they paced the cold streets of
Aberdeen providing Aid to those who have
nothing
a group of people who bring help to the
homeless in Italian more escalating
crisis I started over a year ago now and
when I started we were seeing kind of up
to 20 people a day giving them blankets
sleeping bags food and clothes whenever
they needed it now because of the cost
of living crisis and also the
homelessness crisis we're seeing it can
be up to about 65 people a day
talk me through what life is like on the
streets at the moment
Gary hasn't had somewhere to call home
for more than 30 years this winter he
says is worse than ever this is the name
it's just you just want to give up a
pill left behind my situations but
there's no facilities out there no other
people
the most recent official statistics
paint a grim picture they reveal around
250 homeless people died here in
Scotland last year much higher than
pre-pandemic times and a deteriorating
Trend which is causing grave concern for
what lies ahead it's a massive concern
but the biggest issue for me within that
is the age profile of people the vast
majority are under 45 and the trauma of
experience and homelessness that does
lead to premature aging it leads to
worsening of health conditions this is a
survival map and it takes 44 crisp
Pockets here in Inverness Jillian makes
sleeping bags for the homeless using old
crisp packets a cost-effective idea with
far-reaching benefits
the group that I'm part of and they got
feedback from a guy who sleeps on the
streets
um and there was like tears in his eyes
he was so delighted with this because
it's just life-changing a small gesture
in just one rural community in a country
where those without a home Fear The Long
Winter ahead Connor Gillis Sky News
well King Charles used his first
Christmas broadcast to sympathize with
those struggling and families struggling
to pay their bills and to praise
individuals and organizations supporting
those in need and let's talk more about
it with Chief Royal correspondent for
Newsweek Jack Royston uh Jack good to
see you today thank you for joining us
um what what did you make of of the
king's speeches I suppose certainly in
terms of that somebody who's very
wealthy themselves talking about the
cost of living or the backdrop of
Windsor Castle did it feel incongruous
or not
some people are definitely will but I
think actually the royal family have
quite a long history of doing this and
you know Charles indeed personally
himself we're trying to focus their
efforts on the people most in need
um it was something I actually we saw in
in 2021 Charles gave the queen speech on
her behalf because she was she had
obviously experienced health problems
and he was kind of sat there on a gold
Throne talking about the cost of living
crisis people picked up on it at the
time and said that it was awful
positioning
um Charles I mean if you look back over
the course of his Reign a lot of his
charity workers focused on trying to
help the people most in need so really
it isn't actually anything new
um I think some people also might feel
it's slightly political in the other
direction that he's drawing attention to
some things that the government might
find quite difficult and uncomfortable
and a lot of people in Britain might
claim same aspects of the cost of living
crisis on certain government policies
but again I think Charles has stayed
just about on the right side of that
line as well and focused on what the
royal family probably do best which is
actually trying to help through their
charitable endeavors
what about religion the defender of all
faiths he was happy to position himself
as and and also those with none
certainly something we probably wouldn't
have expected the queen to ever say
no exactly the queen was very firmly a
Christian and this was very visible in
everything but she said
um and Charles has for a long time tried
to position himself as being a friend of
a much broader cross-section of
religious groups
um yeah there was actually it was long
kind of speculated that he might have a
kind of interfaith coronation and that
was one of the questions that Clarence
House actually attempted to answer on
their website back in the day when he
was the prince of Wales so he has this
long-standing commitment to trying to
represent all Faith groups and here we
also have been talking about
representing those who have no faith at
all so we are seeing some subtle
differences between the way that the
queen did things and the way that
Charles did things and they might not be
as kind of attention grabbing or showy
or headline grabbing as some of the
other Royal debates we have at the
moment particularly those about kind of
Harry and Megan but actually it is quite
interesting to see the subtle ways that
he's changed the way that the Royal
Family do things I'm also standing and
also doing it from inside the chapel you
know we we normally see we saw the queen
usually seated uh with a desk
photographs in the background that that
was different too wasn't it yes and
there is actually one very Deft way in
which that got him out of a bit of a
problem which is that we always have
this debate you know the shots that you
can see on your screen right now show
photographs of royal family members and
so there are always these kind of
recurring debates about who's in the
photos who should have been in and was
left out
um so this Christmas speech is quite
unique in that it came after the Harry
and Megan Netflix documentary which
obviously included some quite dramatic
Bombshells so had Charles been sat at
that desk he would have had to have
taken the decision about which
photographs to include there and if he
hadn't included Harry and Megan it would
almost certainly have been commented on
some would have interpreted it as a
swipe if he had included them it would
have been interpreted as an honor Branch
but by doing this standing in St
George's Chapel he was able to create
the positioning of his the connection
with the queen because obviously he
commented on the fact that it was next
where she was there to rest but he
didn't have to engage with that question
of which photos to have on the desk
he did though not mention them and we
did see lots of images of other members
of the royal family didn't we we did and
the Royal position on that would be that
what we were seeing there was the Royals
at work whereas Harry and Megan not
being working Royals have not done
anything that could be that could be
included as Royal work
um obviously Theory they could have
extended Olive Branch to Harry Megan and
they have chosen not to
um but I I think I absolutely know that
that is what the Royals would say that
they would say that it you know they
were only showing official Royal
functions and but one thing that's quite
interesting is they could actually have
shown Harry and Megan in the days after
the queen died when they did that joint
walk out in Windsor or at the Queen's
funeral or one of the other
commemorative events so they clearly
have made a conscious decision not to
show pictures of them
um interesting Jack Royston from
Newsweek really good to talk to you
thanks so much for joining us
but also this morning the education
secretary's Twitter account appears to
have been hacked it's been posting
tweets promoting a cryptocurrency Julian
Keegan's profile picture has also been
changed to an image of Twitter's owner
Elon Musk
Boxing Day traditional day for hunting
but labor says hunting laws should be
tightened further saying current
legislation allows people to break the
law official figures show that they've
been around
430 convictions under the hunting act in
the last decade but the league against
cruel Sports claims there were 303
reports of suspected illegal hunting
over just five weeks recently the
government says there are no plans to
strengthen the laws
a seven-year-old Ukrainian ice figure
skater who fled the war to live with the
family in Bristol has returned home to
continue his training Gosha and his
mother ironya were among tens of
thousands of refugees who arrived in the
UK under the homes for Ukraine scheme
well earlier this year Sky News filmed
Gosha training here before dancing on
ice judge Matt Evers offered to coach
him Sky's west of England correspondent
Dan Whitehead caught up with the family
who are now back in Kiev
escaping a war zone but still able to
pursue his passion
Gosha staying on the ice was top
priority whether in Kiev or Bristol
now eight months on from fleeing to the
UK he and mother Arena have made the
tough choice to return home we are happy
we enjoy being at home even during this
hard and difficult times
for us exactly this is the right
decision
because Gosha was crying he was
sometimes depressed because he separated
from his father when we arrived
it took us maybe it took me maybe more
than months to adapt because we had so
many changes uh city looked a little bit
depressed uh you can feel that war is in
air there you go and stop cross under
push cross under hold it after appearing
on Sky News dancing on I start Matt
Evers reached out to help the pro
training kept gosh's skills up
now back home constant power Cuts
because of the war been training he's
off to under backup lighting we have uh
you know days without
we are in a normal regime now we uh
train a three five full days per week uh
usually three lessons per day
yes yes
Gosha and his mum spent four months
living with their host Caroline one day
they say they hope to return
we would like uh someday yes return like
tourists
to see Caroline I would like to see them
even in Kiev if if we have peace and
they would like to come show me the best
what is his name
despite the relief of being back home
with family the war and worry continues
before this blackout we had another uh
fear I even forgot about this It Was
Fear all the time and risk of nuclear
um disaster
and it just changes all this nightmare
so I hope
soon somehow the missiles will will
finish
it will be a Christmas under conflict
but one that means they're finally back
home
Dan Whitehead Sky News
you're watching Sky News breakfast
coming up a run through over the
morning's papers many of them leading on
the king's historic first Christmas
message
[Music]
well we've been able to review the
boxing day papers is a journalist and
author Jasmine Alibi Brown and the
sociologist Ashley Frawley uh lovely to
see you both thanks a lot for joining us
um Yasmine to you first the front of the
telegraph lots of the papers covering
The King's Speech we were just talking
about it a short while ago what what did
you make of it do you think you got the
tone right
I didn't watch it
um I have to say I'm not a royalist
um but the Daily Telegraph of course is
a very establishment paper and it's gone
into detail about how he expressed
concern for those going through this
cost of living crisis and the sympathy
he feels and I well I just think it's a
bit like us clapping for nurses isn't it
clapping you can't eat claps you can't
survive on claps you can't eat sympathy
it would have been good if he'd
announced
a a a pile of money from the new king
two food banks say to help them through
this crisis
they are the mo one of the most richest
Clans in the country so I'm really sorry
if I I don't mean to disrespect people
who are
um monarchists but I thought
this really didn't wasn't right for the
Times we're living in Ashley what did
you make of it did it stick in your
throat
I mean it was a fairly safe
um speech as it would be I mean it's a
it's a Christmas it's a Christmas
message
um and so he paid tribute to the areas
of society which are struggling at the
moment as one might expect and of course
it's going to strike a lot of people as
Hollow
um when someone who is so wealthy and
basically offers us kind words
um I do I do kind of agree with that but
um you know this is it's a Christmas
message and it's a lot of emptiness
about light and hope and all these sorts
of things and I suppose there's only so
much expectation one can have
the front of the Sun as well isn't it
Ashley is one of the ones that you
picked out
um and lots of pictures on the front of
the papers also of the royal family at
Sandringham and their first Christmas
service with the king at the helm
yes it's um um very much trying to put
forward a very positive
um picture of the royal family
um downplaying some of the drama of uh
recent months and um I'm not sure that I
mean I I for me it just seems quite an
obvious
um you know media show to kind of put
forward this this harmonious picture of
the royal family and the Future King and
but um everybody knows the subtext
um that's being very very carefully
um orchestrated here which is that
there's a lot of drama going on there's
a lot of drama going on generally in the
country but there's a lot of drama going
on in the royal family
um that they are trying very very hard
to pretend perhaps doesn't exist and I'm
not sure the country will necessarily
buy it but I you know I do wish them um
a happy Christmas as much as anyone
would okay
um well let's move away from the King
speech and Yasmine you've gone to the
front of the guardian and this is a
story about more dad's staying at home
as a result of covid more dads taking on
the child care responsibilities and and
the Home Care responsibilities
yeah and this is because this is kind of
an accidental thing that has happened
because of the years of lockdown and
then working from home and a lot of
people men and women are still working
from home and one of the sort of
extraordinary developments out of this
often happens in history one thing leads
to another and what seems to have
happened is that more dads are not only
working from home
but taking more responsibility for the
children
um and according to the ons for example
um the numbers are higher
um of the of the dads who are
finding also that they've been missing
out which I find the most interesting
and affirming things in this story that
you know the interviews Dad saying I
never I used to go before they woke up
the kids woke up hardly saw them now I
take my daughters to school and it's
changed my life so I think if this
carries on it's a very good thing but
never forget it's still the moms doing
the majority of the work of an unsung
actually too often unsung well indeed
that the numbers going up it was it was
one in 14 men who did that uh caring
role and now it's one and nine so it is
still a very small proportion but it is
definitely at least evening out a little
bit which is great news
um Ashley your next story also about
child care actually in children this is
a story inside the mirror
um and this is Labor's plan for more
free child care for families what are
they proposing
yes so there are talks that labor is
drawing up plans for a major expansion
of free child care that could be worth
around six billion pound per year and
one of the ideas being tabled is to make
30 hours free child care per week
Universal for parents of all two three
and four-year-olds and that of course is
up from you know currently
um three and four year old year olds
only get 30 hours if their parents work
at least 16 hours per week otherwise
they get 15. now of course there are
still going to be gaps here but this is
one of the areas in which policy can
make a huge impact and it's obvious this
is why labor is interested in it and for
one thing you can
um one area in which you can grow the
economy is by getting more people to go
into work and in particular to get more
women into work
um and you can also attempt to close the
gender pay Gap as a lot of women will
leave the workplace when it just doesn't
pay when Child Care is simply too
expensive though are their work
part-time where they will leave all
together
um of course the pay Gap being when
women uh part of it being when women
work fewer hours
um on the other hand you have to really
careful about these kinds of policies
because
um a lot of countries have increased
child care for with the idea of getting
more women into work and the idea is
that by getting women to work you can
pull back other forms of support for
families and you in you improve the
condition of families through the
marketplace but what can happen is if
you are making things a lot harder on a
lot of different fronts and you push
women into work you can push women into
insecure work poorly paid work and this
can mean that there's a um you actually
widen inequalities Between Women of
different social classes and this is
what we've seen across Europe in in
recent years and so we have to be
careful that this doesn't that you know
we have to keep our eyes open to make
sure that a policy that sounds good on
the front of it or on the face of it
isn't actually an attempt to cut welfare
elsewhere interesting way of looking at
it Ashley thanks very much for that and
Yasmine back to covid
um you've picked this story about uh
covert data and it's going to change I
mean they're going to stop announcing
they are right I mean in all fairness of
any of us been paying attention to the
our right really recently at all
no and I think this is this is quite
disturbing a news actually because we've
we can see uh you this this week and the
week before the numbers of covid cases
and even hospitalization cases are going
up
um uh you know we've entered the period
of winter and with all the cost of
living crisis and so on we've got more
people getting colds and flu and we're
getting more people getting covered and
I and I I think there's something very
wrong in giving a message to the people
that it's over it's fine we're living
with covid we don't need to give you the
information
um I I think it's a big mistake and it's
being done for the wrong reasons because
Rishi sunak is is is has all all the
time he's been in government
and not all the time he's been in prime
prime minister
has hated lockdown has hated the fact
that kovid came along and interrupted
the capitalist cycle
but you know it happened and it's
happening again around the world China
is now seeing huge numbers of fatalities
we are interconnected I think this is a
terrible policy okay Ashley your
thoughts
um we have to understand that of course
what's happening around the world is
going to be a little bit different than
what's going to hit us at home
um obviously we have
um we've had a very effective
vaccination program we have built up an
enormous amount of immunity that China
has not um so we have to be a little bit
careful in drawing these kinds of
conclusions globally versus what might
happen at home
okay Ashley and Yasmin thank you very
very much